[تصفيق]
تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه وكيفيه ادارتها
وقود معركه اي مرشح للتاثير في الناخبين
والوصول الى الكونغرس او البيت الابيض
[تصفيق]
تطلع بها اللجنه الفيدراليه للانتخابات
التي تسجل المساهمات الماليه وتراقبنا فقط
[تصفيق]
تمويل المرشحين يتيح القانون للحاصلين على
اقامه رسميه في الولايات المتحده التبرع
مساهمه المتبرعين الصغار وصلت الى نحو 22%
من اجمالي النفقات على الحملات الانتخابيه
قبل عامين نسبه فقد قليلا التمويل الذاتيه
من جانب المرشحين والمقدر بسبعه عشر في
المئه
اما الصيد الثمين فيتمثل برجال الاعمال
واصحاب المليارات الذين يلقون بثقالهم
المالي وراء حملات مرشحيهم قدم 131
مليارديرا منهم تبرعاتهم لبيض في سباقه ضد
ترامب لحسم مجله فوكس
[تصفيق]
ضخوا الاموال يتم ايضا عبر لجان عمل
سياسيا معروفه باك تجمع التبرعات وتقدمها
لحملات المرشحين مباشره مع تحديد قيمه
الاموال المسموح بانتقالها بخمسه الاف
دولار لكل لجنه
فيما ثاني اللجان مستقله وهي سوبر باك
وتشارك في انفاق الاموال لغرض سياسي غير
محدود مثل الاعلانات ودفع الناخبين
المترددين لكن بشكل مستقل عن حملات
المرشحين
جدل متواصل حول نزاهه تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه وتاثير وسائل التواصل الا ان
حجم الانفاق على الحملات ليس معيار دقيقا
لتحديد الفائزين